I have a privilege an honor to have
colleague from the Polish me admission
to the United Nations I gotta do de
Blanca well who is a great expert and I
think that she she long is capable to
cover everything because she she used to
have the big experience during with the
European Union well with the presidency
of Poland the European Union with
different aspects of the European Union
developments including enlargement
including the issues of the human rights
including the issues of the security so
it's important to have Poland results
because in that group Bush a grad group
of four countries Czech Republic Hungary
Poland Slovakia Poland is the real
engine pushing the initiatives in all
the spheres and it would be interesting
to have this dialogue with Agata whom I
invite to have the presentation are you
I feel that everything I am going to to
raise today will be in her presentation
and it will help you to understand where
you know is that so what exactly I'm
interested in the five group of problems
I would like to discuss with a gutter
with you with your participation the
future of Europe and the vision from the
vision grad group we should grad group
in the media if you notice that is being
treated in Europe as the the
troublemaker because pushing the
European Union forum for some for some
adaptation to the contemporary
challenges and particularly last year
before the summit of European Union in
Rome the Michigan group were Poland
played a serious role there is an issue
of the Betty Europe and the question is
what does
it means better Europe and we should
recruit contested at the position of of
the leaders of the Europe like
Chancellor Merkel the the President of
the European Commission who promoting
the idea of two-speed Europe and we
should grad group and pawned
particularly they opposed the idea of
division in Europe based on whatever so
this why the my question will be to all
of us to the experts in D in the room
and then those who are watching us by
watch by web web net so they rejoined
then somewhere in their writings well so
to speak about the future of Europe and
the official grad who is bringing the
new blood the new ideas to Europe and
one of the biggest issue of the for
Europe today the challenges among the
group of the challenges is defense and
security this what I would like also to
discuss today with you with the gutter
I will repeat these issues the the
architecture of the contemporary
European defense so the role of NATO in
the new environment the regional
institutions even the division rod group
has its group of battleground group
groups the central Eastern European
common defense approach we have recently
got the some innovation in the common
defence and security policy of European
Union who trying to encourage the
membership with new approach the
so-called pesco this is the some
permanent
cooperation agreement between the
countries in the in this fear of the
defense and security different
perceptions and it would be interesting
to to speak on that of course the energy
issue one of the challenging because
this part of the European neighboring
who is Ukraine Ukraine is more suffering
of that the one one sided dependence on
the energy supply and this is the
question how the wisher gradual Poland
is looking to move out from this one
source dependence and what what is the
future in for the European energy policy
of course what is irritating for Europe
and is being debated as one of the
dividing factor is migration well
exactly Agora is an expert who who knows
who knows the all these all these
problems with migrants because it's
about human rights and many other issues
I mean well we'll raise during debates
and now got a floor is yours and we are
going well to start informing the
colleagues about the major problems your
vision from Poland side and they'll
remove the these problems to our
discussion involving still absent but I
hope some of them they'll come the
visual grad group join position
[Music]
by me and creating this opportunity to
speak on the Polish for any policy on
the visa grads foreign policies I'm
honored and privileged for to be here
and thank you very much for your
interest as well I prepared a short
presentation and that I hope will help
illustrate the topic and which I hope
you will find useful so my name is Agata
da Wonka and on a daily basis I work in
the Polish mission to the UN were I deal
with UN related issues this is a Polish
mission polish foreign minister and our
ambassador in the middle
I've been asked however to speak about
European Union's security related issues
and regional cooperation and I will do
just that
before that however I will have to say
that views expressed our mine own as I'm
required by my employer I will talk
about what determines the Polish foreign
policy and it's no surprise it's our job
political location and membership in
different alliances so we are partner in
the European Union we are an ally in
NATO and in both cases we want strong
and effective European Union and strong
and effective and NATO among our
priorities is of course regional
cooperation having having close ties
having close cooperation with neighbors
is is working to our benefit and we do
our utmost to keep the relations tight
and effective of course we oppose any
efforts that I am at the stabilization
widening of political division
within the European Union on our
breaking up the transatlantic unity as I
said Europe is very important to us we
are partner within the European Union
our international standing depends on
the efficiency of the European Union
itself and we believe that it brings
benefits economical political and social
ones to all its members and it might
come as a surprise by according to the
latest polls the support rate among
polls for the EU membership is the
highest in Europe and it's 87 percent of
the citizens that declare support for
the European Union
of course the international environment
is changing and because of this new
challenges are ahead of us ahead of
Poland ahead of European Union among
some of them are discussions in the
field of future decision making
processes in the European Union
discussions on energy policy migration
and security and within the visa grad
group we very much share the same views
on those issues and we made it clear
during the Rome summit we when we when
we present at our joint vision on those
topics and you can see the logo of the
Polish presidency of the visitor Greg
group at that time joint joint position
on the future of European Union was at
the time among the priorities of our
presidency in the group and remains to
be so so going into details what we
opposed a small high-speed European
Union which we believe is the step
towards a breakup of the European Union
so what we
argue for is respect for fundamental
freedoms in the single market of the
European Union and we do not agree to
policies being imposed on the European
Union and and III quoted the treaty on
European Union when it's a worry still
when it's made clear that Union shall
act only within the limits of the
competences conferred upon it by the
Member States what we believe in is
effective European Union as I said
strong strong United Union is in the
interest of Poland of the visa grab
group and the whole the whole Union and
to have the really strong and effective
union we have to agree we have to act
conceptually and in line with adopted
values and rules including free
competition and economic freedoms the
question of energy is a very complicated
one and have has many layers so I just
picked up two quotations from the Polish
foreign ministry which actually sum up
the most important aspects for for
Poland in this regard so we advocate for
stable and predictable environment and
to design should come an energy policy
of the Union Union serve what we oppose
is for example North stream to which in
our opinion constitutes a threat to the
whole energy security of the European on
the European Union and the question that
is being very
very broadly discussed is of course the
question of migration you might have
heard that Poland together with other
visa great countries is opposing quotas
within the European Union what we
proposed instead is redoubling efforts
to solve the crisis on on the ground
migration quotas in our opinion would
not serve because as you know within the
European Union there is freedom of
movement of persons so in the end
migrants in this case refugees would
would choose a country they wanted from
the beginning so all you know all you
know that the quotas will not be
affecting and implied on the ground we
we of course recognized dramatic
situations and we try to adjust our
development and humanitarian aid to this
end for example we appropriated together
with other visa gram countries forty
five million euros to protecting Libya's
borders only this year our prime
minister started projecting Syria and in
Lebanon to to build a construct houses
for the Syrian refugees and everything
this is happening on top of our annual
programs within the development it's at
the principle recipients in in our case
our Eastern European countries at he
Opia Kenya Myanmar Palestine Senegal and
sans Anya but as I said recognizing the
demotic situation on the ground we try
to adjust and for example in 2017 we
provided medical care to refugees in
Lebanon Jordan and Iraqi Kurdistan we
also
facilitate our efforts to provide and
make the access to education easier for
for children refugees in Lebanon
regarding the security and the primary
responsibility to protect in Poland it's
not not a surprise belongs to the Polish
armed forces at the same time NATO
remains the key element of collective
defence in Europe and we do recognize it
and we try to be an effective and active
ally and to this end we participate
currently in NATO led missions in
Afghanistan Kosovo Latvia Romania Baltic
States and Ukraine we also participate
in coalition missions which are part of
anti-isis coalition we have our f-16 in
Kuwait we have our troops in Iraq at the
same time at the same time we advocate
that the eastern flank of NATO cannot be
be left unattended and the military
presence there should be should be
increased and it was decided in the
Warsaw summit actually that the interior
eastern flank will be strengthened and
Poland hosts since that time on on its
territory allied forces from us United
Kingdom Romania and Croatia so NATO
remains the key the first alliance for
Poland but we are also active within the
common security and defence policy in
the European Union the general rule in
the skies is that all European efforts
in the security field cannot duplicate
the NATO's policies so they might they
they have to be complimentary but they
cannot duplicate and and be the same
because that will be just wasting the
resources and counterproductive to all
efforts in in the security field since
since some time for European Union is
thinking or has already decided to
strengthen the European defense
capabilities and created the permanent
structure cooperation which Poland and
as well as other aristocrat countries
are a member of we very much hope that
pesco because that's the abbreviation of
the permanent structure cooperation we
will remain inclusive and open and that
with in pesco fred's from the south and
east will be treated evenly because
pesco is aiming at increasing defense
capabilities and include the development
of European defence as a whole it also
involves European defence fund and here
we hope that all projects founded from
the European defence fund will be will
be will be directed or realized with
with with equal chances to everyone who
is willing meaning that not only the
major conglomerates defence
conglomerates will be prioritized in
this field but also smaller companies
will be able to participate and expand
their defence capabilities and as I said
opponent is very active in this field
and after I mentioned the nato-led
missions I couldn't not mention the
European led missions that Poland is
participating and the missions that we
you're currently taking part in our
Domitian's in Georgia Bosnia and
Herzegovina Central African Republic
Libya Mali
Atalanta maritime operation of the coast
of Somalia since February operation
Sofia in the Mediterranean and Ukraine
and Moldova most of the time these are
training missions but but we have both
the troops and the equipment there
including including ships fighters and
everything you can probably imagine as
for the regional cooperation as I said
it remains our priority in the field of
foreign policy we make huge effort to
reinvigorate all the organizations that
we are part of a visa grad group
included what we notice is that there is
a common interest within the visa grad
group to present our opinions together
we have strong ties in the security and
military fields battle group as as was
mentioned but not only we also cooperate
with in areas that is that are more
business oriented and we also together
participate in other initiatives and
projects and one example of such
initiative is a free seas initiative
which tries to overcome the
infrastructural barriers from the past
and developed project that will
facilitate transport energetic products
but also like digital economy and move
the region forward at the same time
tightening the the bonds between
participating States and that's actually
what I prepared for you and I hope it
will be a
good basis for discussion thank you
thank you gotta so you just briefly
covered what I and for this discussion
so coming back to the beginning the the
European Union the unity of European
Union you mentioned the position well
after the brexit many hard exits
appeared in Europe Greek exit we heard
about the Czech exit and so on what do
you think what is prevailing in in the
European European building policy of
this unity centrifugal or central part
of the engine seized what people are
disappointed with the developments or at
least they still optimistic at least for
Poland is but within the budget at home
if they all sharing this optimism in the
future of Europe some differences so I
would say that I hope that some kind of
optimism is sure among the visa grad
group its it's really difficult to to
say of course the environment is
changing and there are new and new
challenges being created directed being
one of them and it's it's obvious that
European Union right now is undergoing a
very difficult discussion and has to
take some decisions and it very much
depends I think also the approach of the
visa grad group on how the European
Union will move forward and what
decisions will be taken if the European
Union will be advocating for for
inclusiveness then then I think
that will be very optimistic as I as I
said we very much hope to have a strong
effective European Union because it has
a direct influence on on Polish but also
other EU member states international
standing and this view is proudly shirt
and everyone is aware of it so we should
just try one of the leaders in
officially grad group Medi statement
that the group who prefers to have more
power to the Capitals than to have them
accumulated in Brussels what does it
mean that too much suzerainty shirt
sooner it pulled serenity were given to
the Brussels
what what what does it mean so shoot
something to be bring back because
because I understand that they pulled
serenity from the very beginning is the
core of the European Union but now so
the Capitals the they understand that
too much serenity were moved to the to
the Brussels and these grades well some
some tensions members that can be forced
to do anything no EU policies must be
imposed on Member States they should all
agree to it and it's already in the
treaties of the European Union so they
just have to be implemented okay
understand so and it it's more it covers
or it concerns or all the
all these fears of European Union
responsibility or some concrete fears
economic financial human rights defense
or some separate spheres were you think
that too much serenity moved to the
Brussels I think it should be just
adopted as a general rule I'm not
exposing X enhance cooperation but
enhance cooperation should mean that
it's even if few Member States decide to
discuss a few issues on their own and
enhance their cooperation in this regard
that that the possibility of joining the
group should be still open and left to
others so like not to exclude anyone I
understand from your presentation what
you're explaining now that the bush-rat
group demands Poland demands that before
any decision to be tabled in the
Brussels the draft should be discussed
and adopted in the capital's situation
and to the fact that there is there are
like it's already an open discussion
that there is a deficit in democracy
within the institutions and so okay so
you're demanding the democratic
legitimacy in a way anyway okay no let's
take as it is welcome one of the
complicated issues is the defensive
security so for the last two decades
least so we had well relative truths in
an European continent but recently so
the the situation has changed and the
debates around the defense and security
appeared in Brussels and the capitals
and so my question is
first of all what are the major
challenges we sure glad group as a group
in in the in the domain of security
shares either the the same challenges
are coming to to all of you or only to
those who are well have the common
borders with Russia and those who don't
the they don't feel that there is some
external military threat to them what
exactly the the challenges to the
defended security do you think in the
group prevailing to have any kind of
aggression to have kind of the military
attack what what what is need for the we
should not group to have their own
troopers grouping to have the action
plan to have the permanent meeting of
the ministries of Defense to debate
parallel to what the the regional
situation is that in that region there
is the common security defense approach
from from the group where Poland is not
a member but observer as observed from a
side or you think do the region needs
this kind of the cooperation is it
helpful to the general European
integrity in the in the security demand
or not so why this regional
institutions are needed I will once
again go back to NATO and say that it
still remains like our major defense
alliance and having said that I would
say that regional cooperation is always
helpful taking into account the fact
that there are different defense
capabilities within different states
this kind of cooperation my only enhance
the capabilities and work into for for a
joint better result also under NATO
umbrella the threats are of course
different now than they were a few years
ago and the threat coming from the east
is the one that we openly recognize and
that's why we made clear that we should
not neglect this and this Fred and why
we deal with the threat coming from the
south we should hand-in-hand discuss and
consider threats coming from from from
the east what we hear this again so
exactly the the action plan of Asia grad
group in defense cooperation which is
adopted and working now so says that
NATO remains the guarantor for security
credible collective defence and
deterrence in the center of European
region it's good to to know that all
four countries who signed under this
action plan they recognize the niche
role of course if you look at the
national defence strategy of Hungary of
Czech Republic Slovakia well you find
that for for these three which grad
group countries the major challenge is
coming from the south with migration for
Slovakia not 100% but partly the danger
from the east is evident and for Poland
is absolutely evident so despite the
fact that the priorities are was
probably different in the national
strategy the four fishing rod group
countries they are united in
understanding that NATO is the is a
pillar for the security in the region so
is this good is good to take it account
when we are moving
to the Pasco this is the the invention
which was supported by majority of the
of the countries this is interesting
decision that which are taking by the
Brussels if for many of the defense
issues Brussels demands consensus for
Pascoe the demand was just to have the
majority so that's why some of the
countries like Malta they did not join
Pascoe but we sure glad group supported
supported last time during the last
meeting round table we had the the
Baltic States and they explained why
they accepted accepted Pascoe
particularly stony so when they
recognize that Pascoe is not comparative
it's not confronting is not well
something which is doubling but adding
to the NATO in Europe they they agreed
to support that and well they explained
the remains when this cooperation or
this coincidence of approaches between
Pasco and NATO could be found the
cybersecurity the transportation the
logistics the which could be helpful and
the question to discuss briefly now but
at any rate we have pesco Pascoe has 17
programs Pascoe invites all the
countries to to participate in one at
least at one of them so Poland as I know
it for me is taking part in two of them
very important military mobility and
European security software software so
this is well
they advanced defense institutions my
question is well which had put before
the Baltic states and they explained in
a way that they are open to work both
for NATO and for Pascoe my question was
and is not all the country's NATO
members they are paying the the two
percent commitments of their budget to
the to the NATO budget only five
countries including Poland who are
facing these commitments the rest there
are five had even the Western countries
West European countries like Netherlands
Luxembourg they pay less than one
percent so and the question is that if
some countries they are not ready to pay
for the for the main body they have
members to how they can pay in the net
contribute to the Pascoe which also
demands some money so this is some kind
of conflicting what I was explained by
the the the Baltic States that so they
are trying to to use the same money
they're paying to today to adopt the the
programmes of pesco they are involved in
to what already exists there so this is
one of the complicated issue well just
to remind you that at the beginning of
the nineties after the collapse of the
Soviet Union the the many if not the
majority of the European countries after
the Warsaw Pact was
so the demand is safe for NATO we don't
in NATO because was a Warsaw Pact
disappeared no enemy anymore and only
the group of the countries from Central
and Eastern Europe including Poland and
some from the Russian girl group who
insisted to keep it to keep NATO and so
they were right and they they had
reasons for that in mid nineties just to
remind you that there was a German
initiative supported by friends to have
the European army well something
parallel to the to NATO and was severely
opposed by Britain not to have the
parallel structures and not to spend
paid double for the European defence so
when Britain was there so no initiatives
to have the parallel structures but when
Britain declared about its exit well so
initiatives came back and so we got we
got Tesco and it is good to have the the
strong stand of division grade group and
Poland with one of the major partners of
NATO in the region that the opposing any
doubling of native there and for them
need is remains and will remain as one
of the major factor of stability yeah
just for you to to remind that still we
have this parallel movements around the
European defence and security when
ambitions to have something typical
European as it was declared several
times including recently that Europe is
for Europe
and America should care about the other
part of the world particularly when the
tragedy of 9/11 happened and the United
States changed the the angle to the to
the sources of the of the extremism
which mostly were not in Europe and so
it was a moment when some European
leaders thought okay so leave Europe for
us with defence and security and do care
about yourselves or whatever you want
and now situation is changing so even if
the ideas initiatives are coming to have
something parallel so the the realities
which are close to the visual art groove
and Poland the demonic to have NATO to
have native there okay so this is about
the military component of the security
but what is in the package both of NATO
and the in pesco areas cyber security
information security and why it matters
why cyber security and information
security is so important why Poland is
chosen in the amount of the 17 the
projects one which related to the to the
cyber Poland recognizes cyber security
as a possible threat in our defense
strategy and that's why we we are
engaged in two project in this area we
to recognize that there is a need to
step up our efforts industrial in this
regard and
prepare our so better and firefight it's
simply better at the same time as with
other friends we believe that the joint
effort is necessary and we should work
on it together within NATO and European
Union okay so we can continue this
discussion around that point information
and cybersecurity and living this this
part of the discussion just to to tell
you that within the different region
combinations around the common efforts
to protect the security environment
there there is one which most was
probably more symbolic but is very
important to demonstrate is solidarity
Ukraine Poland and Lithuania we created
the joint joint battalion few years ago
well this is a demonstration of
solidarity - as as it concerns the some
kind of the deterrence was probably
psychological political death rates for
those who have any aggressive intentions
towards the region energy I have you
explained about nor two nor two this is
well the second pipeline parallel to the
north one which was initiated by Germany
and Russia
before and is interesting well that
Chancellor Schroeder's stand behind this
initiative now he is one of the top
managers in Gazprom well so this
bilateral idea which is looking for the
support and they are getting support in
in some of the European countries some
European energy agencies in France and
in Austria the the adjoining list
project and so the question is that a
lot of the attractiveness in that
project so it brings additional gas to
Europe it will bring the reduction of
the prices it will come to to Germany
then the the German Germany pipeline
opal is running to the south and
entering Czech Republic the Czech
Republic Republic is the country on the
west of bashad group and and then using
the Czech net for well to move this gas
further
so and and the question which is being
circulated now in Europe what was the
danger what is the danger if it brings
additional gas which will reduce prices
and the the existing pipelines it would
be used well to supply gas to the
countries in need including including
the visual grad group this is the
question which is the proponents of this
of this of this line they are spreading
around the question is of the danger and
what is their alternatives to that so I
have my answers but I propose mine as as
well
and so one of the principle of European
common policy is to act in the direction
of diversifying the gas supplier in
Europe the eastern part of Europe is
very much dependent on the Russian gas
so Nordstrom too is doing nothing else
than increasing the dependency of Europe
on the Russian gas that's why Poland has
a very firm position on this opposing
the construction of nordstrom nordstrom
true to what we propose what we try to
do in exchange in addition to of course
loudly opposing the idea is to develop
the LNG's we have we already have one in
Genosha in the north of poland and we
try to engage regional partners to join
forces with us and
and cooperate in this regard to really
diversify the gas suppliers and use
other sources than just Russians right
now the the dependency of Poland is
actually decreasing because we are using
us from the US as well as from the
Middle East thanks to the LNG we have
but it's still not enough and it's still
not a Nordic gas which is running
through then Denmark and then obviously
a Polish and an Eastern European problem
but it's also a problem that affects the
secure energy security of the whole
European Union as a bloc clear so the
European European energy policy is based
on three principles that there is a
solder there is a buyer solar could not
be a buyer it means that Gazprom should
not buy from Gazprom in Europe it means
that they a lot of the sister companies
in Europe which are mostly governed by
Gazprom the second is that if you are
supplier you can't be at the hundred
percent transporter and to control all
the transportation this is what the
European Union opposed around the North
stream one and the rest of the projects
in in the regional Baltic over the Black
Sea so there are several similar
projects well which are being denied
rejected by European Union because the
Russia dominance there as a transporter
is is clear and and then well the the
the last but not the least so being the
the major supplier so the Russia has an
Excel
to to influence the European energy
policy generally so it means that what
exists should be adapted to this to
these realities so that is why there is
why unfortunately so it was a good
project supported by European Union
Nabucco if you have a head the the gas
to be supplied from the Caspian region
through the Baltic States you know
through the Black Sea states and then
the Visegrad woman to the rest of the
you of Europe so raw Russia in that
region supports South Stream supports
Tesla sounds very good Tesla very close
to the Czech and Slovak well European
Union backed East ring pipelines wide
stream but all of them they are pending
to bring the gas from Caspian Caspian
region turkey is trying to play a role
of the energy hub well all the mentioned
pipelines should move through through
Turkey this is also something which is
contradictory to the to the European
energy policy it's interesting what a
goddamn mentioned in her presentation
about the three C's initiative
intermarium it started with two seas and
at the beginning of the last century and
nowadays about three seas including
Adriatic Sea and the one of the projects
there is to link the the the terminals I
mentioned in this video we share with
those who are in in Adriatic and one of
the projects to build want to improve
the railway and roadway communications
how to supply it further well as well it
is not mentioned but as interesting well
to know to take note that after the
position of
Germany which was not favorable to the
development of nuclear energy in Europe
now the region is is coming back to the
idea to have nuclear power stations
which is not easy because those existing
in Bulgaria in Czech in Slovakia in
Ukraine they are dependent on Russia
Russia fuel nuclear fuel supply and the
countries in the region they are doing
also looking for the diversification of
that so nuclear energy ok and moving to
migration I guess that I gotta I said
clearly about that there is it was but
now it is diminishing it was one of the
contradictory issue between the Russia
grad group and the and and Europe so now
the the situation is improving and it
says to me that we should girl group
made everything correctly to explain
Brussels what is needed that it is not
against the migrants it is a great
against the the lagoons the the gaps in
the existing migration policy in Europe
generally so what European Union should
do well to help the the countries of
origin well to to encourage their people
not to move out so it means new jobs
whatever so you mentioned that we are
donating to Libya you're involved in
that Europe also a part of that so and
what is important according to the
international instruments international
legislation who should care about the
migrants the country of the first
arrival
they should care about them and then to
take the decision what to do next
of course there is a big burden for the
countries like Greece like Italy like
Slovenia who are the first who are well
meeting the migrants what to do with
them they don't have enough money we
hold in our facilities and what they are
doing simply they're opening doors
borders move further and they are moving
further to the to the countries like
those innovation grad group the major
issue I am preparing for this kind of
the debates is that the first countries
they have the responsibility
responsibility to verify they verify who
are refugees among migrants who should
get the the better better support which
are provided by the international law
all the refugees are migrants not all
the migrants are refugees all the
refugees are well protected by the
international law not all the migrants
are protected by the law still there are
the base in the United in the United
Nations about the protection of the
climate migrants they've been rejected
well the scandals recent scandals around
the the Australian policies as to the
migrants from the disappearing Islands
there so and others there is no
protection of migrants who are coming
for coming for the better social or
economic conditions and this is exactly
what the vision girl group demands from
you well let's let's agree what to do
well not easy No
is the issue but it is about the about
the general approach of the world
community what to do right actually in
New York right now there are global
negotiations on migration that probably
[Music]
that try to solve the issue and decide
what to do next recognizing that the
problem of migration crisis crisis but
also recognizing the problem of climate
climate migrants and just on the margins
I will say that it somehow adds to the
polish efforts to help resolve the
problems on the ground and I'm saying it
also to underline that in in in the
context of climate migrants Poland is
the only country that will host the
climate conference in Poland for the
fifth time this year and and for sure
the problem I wrongly probably I wanted
to say will host the conference for the
fifth time and the conference will
happen this year in in December in in
Poland and the problem of climate
migrants will for sure be mentioned
during the discussion in Katowice by the
way industrial city in in Poland but
just to illustrate that the whole world
recognizes that the problem and they
need to discuss migrations and and move
forward great so now I'm inviting you
well with your questions your comments
well I was in a garage shoes several
years ago I do understand how diplomat
eliminate I am NOT limited I will try to
be correct a generator in my comments
but I don't stand
well the the limitation of the a-frame
division
yo capacities well well if if we openly
said that we support it then we do
support wild checks will oppose it I
don't know I'm sorry
hmm so checks proposed it yeah
I do know the about the bank something I
missed in that I know that there are
funds different funds to support
different different projects including
including defense and security well the
local funds for the local projects well
about the bank there is something we
have lost the checks about for because
well look at this situation the only
country in the bush a girl group who is
linked to the euro is Slovakia the rest
be the enjoy to have their own own kind
of currency it's interesting well very
interesting and so if you look at the
economic data so these three are the
more advanced in the Industrial
Development well
Slovakia is well progressing but not not
so rapidly as the rest Poland during the
first quarter gave the biggest figures
in Europe as to the industrial growth
well how the the the fact that Slovakia
is linked to the two euro well works for
badly good well I don't know so we have
different different interpretation from
different different countries either
they enjoy or not for example Greeks
they are not in favor to to be in Euro
because when they had drama so the
situation were more or less stable but
again to bring back to bring the new new
problems and to destabilize the
situation so a lot of the debates
but probably the the banking system will
demanded some kind of the well a linkage
to some talk to some of the currencies
to euro I don't know if if you have any
well let's look from the point of view
who is around that so China is very
active in the region you know of the the
only Asian country who was invited to
participate in do you know this format
sixteen plus one plus one is China
sixteen Central and Eastern European
countries China participated in well
[Music]
again yes
so I would start with saying that we
have a very similar legacy and very
similar experiences from the past and
this primarily brought us together also
the immediate proximity and neighborhood
that creates a natural group out of us
and if you look in the past those were
the values like the very similar job
political views past experiences also
interest in security in migration they
brought us together and they delivered
very feasible results which proved that
the cooperation is working and for and
to exemplify what I just said for
example that we see broad group like
every
significant Asifa control and moving the
enlargement process of the European
Union forward having four countries
together which have the population of 60
million people I guess
that's that's a strength that others
should really take into account so it
already worked showed that we can
achieve something together and from
there we we moved forward we are also
trying to bridge the gap of of the
develop degree of economic development
with the Western countries so we are on
the same side of the spectrum dealing
with similar troubles and trying to
catch up with with the Western with the
Western Europe and we have a very
pragmatic view on many issues and while
for example the whole Western Europe is
looking to the south we might direct and
bring up the issues that are important
to our region and that what keep us
together values is one thing interest is
another issue
and also the effectiveness that was
shown in the past
beginning with the immigration crisis do
you think that the bonds are keeping the
aristocrat group together was an
official official organization my sub
solution over time what do you think
that basically the links are so strong
that you might be seeing this with a new
center of gravity it's it's always
difficult to predict but I would say
that I'm not expecting a sudden
loosening of of bonds giving the fact
that we have similar very similar
problems as a whole and given the fact
that we are already having a very close
cooperation and use some methods of like
like communication methods are already
there I going back to the question of
the bank if an issue was product the
consultations among the aristocrats
group are taking place very often and
they are conducting on various levels
starting from a highest political level
to the expert level so it's like a day
that every day they work so III don't
expect the to suddenly losing because
yet we are in a very similar position
collaboration Nazi perhaps you were
creating a two-speed Europe so I I think
the position is very new as we are
opposing the multi-speed euro but at the
same time as I said we are not against
the enhanced cooperation and I would say
I would see the visa grab group more as
an enhanced cooperation we are working
together while multi-speed Europe in my
understanding would exclude us from
working together because would prevent
us for taking part in some decisions if
we want it
while enhance cooperation keeps the door
open and I think that's the major
difference in these two approaches I
mean as we all know of the 28 while
there's 27 member states only 19 use the
Euro so we in reality we have a
two-speed Europe you know who would like
to come up with a common approach to
taxing budget you know financial
policies would you be opposed
you know every member state when they
sign off
they also say at some point if they
fulfill the convergence criteria able
join the Euro group so you are not
excluded from from these discussions but
I mean as long as you are not part of
the Euro group I think it's okay for the
Euro group to come up with some common
policies and and learn from the lessons
of the financial crisis so that's why in
reality you already have a two-speed
Europe at two-speed Europe because of
the Euro but that doesn't mean that you
will be excluded from joining the if you
will there the pirate eye care group if
you wish to do so
and the other thing that I wanted to
understand is you know you said that
there is a lack of democratic
participation in the decision-making of
of the European Commission and
russell's as far as I know over the
President of the European Council sets
the agenda right before every meeting of
the European Council which is the heads
of states all the characters will have
to say yes we agree or disagree I am not
quite sure how Russell is now excluding
especially the recent product nations or
Poland it just in all honesty I'm a
citizen of the Federal Republic of
Germany stuff but I know all the ins and
outs of the European Union so I don't
think everyone anyone is excluding
excluded here but you know you know
former polish Prime Minister Donald Tusk
is the president of the European Council
you know he speaks basically for the
entire European Union and gives the
direction if you will to the European
Commission to carry out and and some of
the sovereignty that has been given up
as part of the European treaties like
the single market and common customs
union so there are certain things that
member states cannot legally do by
yourself so I would like
Thank You defrag each hunk ahead that's
the all stolen and answering the
question on the Euro I would say I would
say that that's difficult because Poland
is obliged to implement the euro as a
conference in Seoul at the edge we know
that once we fulfill the criteria and
while our economy is ready we will be
joining the eurozone so in this moment
making decisions without countries that
for sure sooner or later but will be
part of the eurozone is actually
excluding them that's my point of view
as for the European Commission yes the
Council of the president of of the
European Council is setting an agenda
and and we know it when we speak about
democratic deficit what we have in mind
are for example obligatory quotas which
we oppose that is something imposed from
above without the consent of the Member
States so that's when we say that there
is a need to discuss issues get all
countries and board and then move
forward especially given the
significance of of the decisions that
have to be
taken on one hand we have the
possibility of obligatory quarters and
on the other hand we have the argument
that the quotas will not be working
anyways because people will be moving to
the most developed countries within the
European Union so that's the issue that
we rise when we think of when we speak
about the Democratic deficit yep taking
into account that we do recognize the
President of the European Council is
setting an agenda yeah well it is it is
good question about the many speeds in
Europe and I was thinking of many times
how what what are the arguments to put
on the table when those who met in Rome
before the summit several countries for
the Western Europe who initiated the
idea Italy including that we have to sit
you and we are to put in the in the
final document but if if you look the
data's what about speed in youth
unemployment for example the euro area
unemployment is average unemployment is
8.5% Michigan who has the lowest check
to point for Hungary's wait Poland four
and five so lucky seven five but still
less they around youth those who
proposed the two-speed Europe Italy 11%
Spain 16% the question is
who is ahead who is behind what is about
the two speeds well so if we take the
the dynamics
well Poland demonstrate in the end of
last year the second largest industrial
growth the speed in Europe that is in
the well in the second circle of Europe
the system works better than in eurozone
so it is very difficult to to to bring
the arguments if of course we have to
speed you the old Europe
the first members they are demanding
that they are more advanced GDP of
Slovakia is higher than in Poland is
inspired by Hungary and Czech Republic
Poland Poland test of the nominal GDP
for European countries Poland is the
tenth Czech Republic is 18
Hungary 21st lucky 23rd it's believed
they say the nominal GDP for European
countries in below us
GDP per capita I need you you know
lately Stein has the highest GDP per
capita because they have kind a little
population so what I'm trying to say is
you know if you are going to bring up
some numbers it is not going to help us
to you know when you say and it is true
: had the highest growth rates within
the European Union also Romania lately
also had very high report rates what I'm
trying to say is having certain growth
rates above average is not going to make
you of the euro area or help you to have
a say in certain financial policies of
the euro area in order to be able to
make that those kinds of proposals
minute you need to be remembered as a
life term as she already indicated when
the convergence criteria are met Poland
will be a member of the euro area and I
think I have the impression polar almost
is meeting those criteria but they are
having kind of second guesses where they
should
join the euro would you agree with that
aye aye I honestly have no idea
I I don't know the data so I just cannot
say I would say that they really obliged
us to to have euro adopted once we are
ready so I'm honestly don't go okay but
anyway so that there is no exact
criteria how to judge are they because
if to take data as as I am proposing so
I agree with you it's reading some
confused because if to take the Human
Development Index which compose
everything so the world highest Norway
Norway so which is not in eurozone not
the European Union because they don't
want to wait for quarters for fishery
and forget well that's why they don't
want to be they are their partners
yeah yeah so but what is interesting
this is the world ranking so from the
region Czech Republic is the first 28th
position in the world among 133
countries Poland 36 Slovakia 40 Hungary
47
well so of course they are prepared for
that of course the they have all the
arguments more than some of the
countries in the Eurozone
well they observing what United Kingdom
did they were not in the eurozone of
course of course but the question but
the question still exists but it's true
that the the European Union members they
are debating that the official drug
group opposing but what it exists is
true so what does it mean to speed
Europe does it mean to Europe's or this
war Europe because the the Baltic states
they joined in that support rejecting
this approach because it is dividing
dividing Europe so your question about
the the the other interests so we should
rock group is the biggest I understand a
regional partner for Baltic States and
they have a lot of cooperation programs
including defense including the
transportation and as far as energy
terminals were mentioned and the bank by
the way
so why the bank is needed but either it
should be
I think that the question appeared
because what we should read group
supports originally is beyond special
group itself you mentioned Agata
intermarium intermarium it has several
big projects which can't be financial
unbearable for all these countries of
course if these projects are going
we had European Union involved and the
countries who already expressed interest
who participated and all these meetings
China United States Japan so that's why
the bank if it is should cover the
projects of the linkage between Adriatic
and the Baltic as to the railroads
so-called via via Baltics something like
that we are Baltics and then the second
one is the via Carpathia so no this is
what the package of the inter Mario 3
C's so and it is not about the bank of
the vision graph group there is
something beyond that which could
accumulate the money for in all these
projects maybe it could be some some
funds within the initiative 3 C's which
last year was visited in Warsaw by
President Trump and so the message was
very concrete and supportive homeless
projects so I understand that the region
the region is very very energetic was
probably troubling the Brussels with new
initiatives but the were you looking as
I understand from being a neighbor that
they are trying to help themselves when
the message from here
percent that guys defend yourself as it
was sent to Japan as well so the Russian
girl group was the first to discuss what
to do and they took the decision well to
contribute more for their regional
defense at the same time to support NATO
presence there
so NATO is back supported by by United
States and the United States is a major
a major partner there so it means that
the region is looking for the new issue
initiatives how from their integration
and to help themselves to make the
integrity of European Union more closer
and not not to have any divided dividing
lines they are to overcome all these
things because a lot of the new
challenges are coming not only from
energy sector not only from the
migration not only from the security not
all together
so they need the new impetus to move
ahead to modernize themselves this is
what I'm dreaming about my own country
who is not a member just just around
that but this is what is needed for for
Ukraine as well any other questions
please
energy source of diversification into
other than
[Music]
[Music]
yes is also the fossil fuel so there's
not much there reciprocation there
Stuart Ziff environmental groups are
active in Poland oh and if you have any
influence on Cochin
and if they're willing to pay taxes
higher taxes to subsidize solar energy
energy
[Music]
yeah I I all say the discussion is
obviously present in Poland you might
have heard about the pollution problems
we are having so that's at least one
facilitator of the discussion of course
we are having our internal determinants
that have a huge influence on the
discussion dependency on call of the
Poland's economy at the other hand we
are as other European countries
supportive of the very diversifying
regarding the resources and for example
III I haven't seen the latest rankings
but I know as Hamas is doing a banking
on green cities in in Europe and in this
ranking also is moving up steadily at
least
yeah that's to be check how it looks
like in 2018 or 2017 but I'm sure
discussion is ongoing people are very
much aware and we are doing our efforts
regardless of of other determinants and
as I say as I said the summit the
climate summit will obviously be be a
place where those issues will be
rainforests and discussed more actively
and also the place of the sub as a meat
cutter Peter should be treated very
symbolically because that's that's that
how to say that the major city that's
associated in Poland with with coal mine
industry so that's already saying in
which direction Poland wants to go and
ask for now Poland is meeting its
commitment regarding co2 emissions and
and Europe as us as a whole is actually
the place that has the highest chances
of meeting the very the very ambitious
goal is setting up on itself so that
would be my comment on it you replacing
some of those by EU projects or even
efforts is that an avenue that is select
the even AMI maybe instead of
duplicating existing needs of efforts
that could take over the serving of
those aspects I would say
[Music]
that the principle of complementarity
that's the principle that was accepted
by both European Union and NATO the the
possible problem I would see in
replacing some of the NATO functions in
the way would be that the membership of
NATO and membership of European Union is
different so that's the obstacle I would
see but on the other hand depending on
what we are talking about there are
probably ways where you could take over
at the same time the most problematic
thing is just application and in a way
waste of resources which are limited
okay thank you very much let me think
yesterday
[Applause]
[Music]
you